hey guys I'm Ryan right so today I'm
gonna be checking out the comic-con
trailer for the spin-off of fear The
Walking Dead okay fear The Walking Dead
let's see if this show because the
walking dead people are complaining it's
becoming a little repetitive so I'm
hoping this spinoff isn't just a repeat
hey you got five minutes just say come
in
Jesus mom I just saved us change but I
don't want to come it's my weekend Renzo
no today all of us fine wash me that
morning Maddie no kids out sick today
I thought you were another victim no I
got my flu shot all right what is London
trying to teach us here
London's trying to teach us how not to
die now what is man versus nature
man may offer warmth he may offer food
the nature always wins your scent is
lucky witnesses said he ran into traffic
it was high he was ranting what happened
everyone was dead there was blood
leaving this what you saw was a
nightmare hallucination
safer numbers save her from what they
don't know if it's a virus or are micro
stressed they don't know but it's
spreading
check this out someone leaked the
footage with us how they unload on him
it's not real and can't be real
where are you I gotta go I gotta go
excuse me sir we're closed we need place
to write it then you what was that sound
oh you see out there
it's like it's not real where are you
we're stuck
far away from
when civilization ends Dan's fast
nice and easy yeah
whoa you guys can't see cuz the cameras
further away than usual but I got nipple
chills right now legit nipple chills
look you see that direct nipples right
now
oh man I'm [ __ ] impressed just off the
trailer alone I'm impressed
okay first thing I noticed they're
shooting it completely different it just
looks different The Walking Dead has
more of a you know grittier type of vibe
to it not saying this isn't gritty it
feels actually more cinematically
captured than The Walking Dead and I
like the timeframe in which this takes
place because the Walking Dead as all
you know it starts off in normal world
and then it just cuts to when the
world's being run over by zombies this
is exploring the time when the virus was
spreading and then zombies were starting
to happen and rather than brushing past
all that we're seeing the details of
that while following this family it's
cool to see cliff Curtis and a lead
cliff Curtis I've seen him in movies for
decades now and he's one of those actors
that when you say cliff Curtis most
people aren't gonna know who he is but
he's the dad in this and he looks like
he's doing a great job and it's cool
that he's a star of a show where he gets
a chance to really shine and get his
name out there proud of you but more
importantly Lorenzo James Henry
oh my god I first met this kid when I
was in eighth grade now he is all grown
up he has become one sexy [ __ ]
like when he was young people are like
he's gonna be one hot ass dude when he's
older and he's grown up and he is one
sexy ass Lorenzo if you're watching this
fear the walking head the walking road
head yeah show looks cool I'm I will so
be there I'll watch the premiere and
everything anyway guys if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine
Lorenzo call me call me as soon as
possible message me Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine pancreas not
pancreas prospect what's the [ __ ] is
that new app I just downloaded periscope
I almost said prosthetic